I feel it's my duty to bring the calls
between President Obama and president
like trump directly to you the American
people here's the latest batch hello hey
it's me
I told you never to call her again yeah
I don't let you do stuff like that
listen you see my tweet about Meryl
Streep yes it was ridiculous she's a
beloved figure and an incredibly
talented actress she don't care read
they say I thought a disabled reporter
you clearly did it's on tape I don't
bite people yes you do you do it all the
time
yes hello hey bear what should I do
about Joyce Korea I think you have to be
firm but not inflammatory maybe even
increase sanctions on them as long as
they keep up this threatening rhetoric
oh I would just go to Greg off gift
Justin and duck it a funny asian boy you
know furious about all the negativity
I'm getting from Hollywood lately yeah I
read about that I am going to do
something about it what are you gonna do
well what's it called when you make a
list of subversive people to make sure
no one hires them a blacklist no I
already have that Andy for whitey
[Applause]
thirty-five
you